[Music]
so we'll just start with the and my hand
is going to come up above the elbow and
I use my anchored elbow just to move
this back to my shoulder outside elbow
outside and we wish you all the way to
make sure don't go past your shoulder
you're going to overextend only defend
your bottom so my hand goes too much and
while my hand perpendicular to the arm
so I don't want to do this everyone as
much mass as I can at the deflection
angle
so notice how my hand is moving not here
turn turn just like cut tucked ahead
right
so my hand turn okay so this is where
the Aikido starts to fail because you
actually have a basic which you're not
using into basically using it as an
application so you would do grab so I do
you could touch a Doherty right so you
know here you have a righty evening on
your right you see attention on my arm
and the shape of my arm
okay and then you go to ski like in this
drill and now you're doing this and this
this is until we're into the heart okay
so what what katatetori is teaching you
is a particular body organization where
you have structural integrity it ameno
let's just take that
let's doing anything but let's just take
that so when he does his punch and I go
like this there's nothing there right
it's not going to have the impact that
you want so my whole body is organized
right everything is organized okay and
those shapes of my arms take to do the
escape
is the shape that I use to keep that
structural integrity so when I go here
and move out of the way and push on me
you see but if I go here right and I'm
here like this and you pushes on me you
can get out of the way you can do the
drill you see I have the same thing same
same exact thing right here you see a V
keel until we're doing he killed boom
and I can move him and I can't do that
if I go like this you see the difference
if I'm bringing a man okay so don't
screw with the form that's why we're
doing it slow and just static so boom if
you need to picture his grip on your
wrist and loose grip on your wrist and
escape his wrist not like this he said
boom the shape shape elbow boom okay
let's go so I add the second hand enough
so if we if he's grabbing right and I
come in here the second hand comes in
right in this second having it don't go
away past your shoulder it goes to your
shoulder to your shoulder okay so I'm
going to go for this one
- one two one two
it picks up when this space here is on
the center line so when his elbow kiss
to the Sun Oy that's where that hand is
and that's exactly what I do in these
techniques I don't go like this right
okay and it'll go like this right this
hand brings it to the center line that's
the space for it right so same thing
with
[Music]
okay let's go alright so once good
once I get letting him go five you see
I'm not stopping him right I'm not
stopping him I'm letting him go by now
now you have the beginning of position
okay so the first thing we want to do is
we want to just extend the Kazushi out
this way this is to get a feeling that
so I'm polling it kinda by letting it go
[Music]
watch how my body goes around that
energy
I'm not doing anything but keeping it
going that way I'm not grabbing them I'm
not projecting him and just move it
around that elbow point
okay so he's already losing his balance
right so here I'm just gonna add to that
right he was falling so he go he's going
you see he's falling I'm just going to
add to that you can see how I'm doing
this so he's already off balance so
cheap I see how you opening it up I have
there the wrist right and the leg oh boy
he's off balance so when I have my
fixated movements like katatetori
it looks like I'm doing gross levers and
fulcrums but as you get more advanced
you realize you're working with the
forces of the engagement and inertia
gravity momentum friction okay so here
you you have to rely on that when it's
ballistic movement you cannot rely on
fulcrums and levers it's too fast okay
but I'm still doing fulcrums and levers
of those forces so as he's coming in
right me not stopping it and me
accelerating it you see as I let it go
by all I have to do now is add these
little touches at the very end I'm not
going like this you guys see that that's
a gross motor skill on you're doing
tactile physical levers and fulcrum so
instead he's going right I'm moving so
the punch is actually I'm not flipping
it I'm just keeping it up do you see
it goes past me keeping it up and I
attack the lip you see it's under half
because it's just a little top
hey let's go this elbow as he says he's
coming in right I don't want it I don't
want it to be a matter oh I'm just
pulling them okay so we're gonna go
really good the other way so it's still
light
oh you'll feel it won't say he's not
here am I going like that he's off
balance full off balance then I tip pull
there and won't let it go there he goes
[Music]
it's light and that's when I feel like I
won't make it so right
this can happen right ideally I should
not be but it can happen right and so
the more that I'm in this range the last
time I have to or I will be able to rely
on foot maneuvers okay my deviation go
ahead right my deviation is more on my
body you see that so wrong body but if I
can as he's punching right I'm ready for
his intention meaning I'm not here on
reaction
right you're you're with him I can get
movement I will
[Music]
okay if I can't get moving I gotta move
my head off the line right my body's
moving
don't expect your big thing where you're
gonna go just need big she will
start close but we don't want is this
you see no effect on his ass okay we're
looking for his mouth to go some offices
boom those are round tops face cake
track so on the crosses for closer right
[Music]